merrick garland is instructing the fbi
to
consider parents who oppose critical
race theory
to be domestic
terrorists
so you do you have kids out there you
listeners i something tells me if you're
listening to this show you probably
don't think all that favorably of
critical race theory you probably don't
support it being taught in schools will
you in the eyes of merrick garland's
department of justice
are a domestic terrorist
all right
the the order that comes out let's see
do i have a copy of the order yes i do
memorandum from the attorney general
in recent months there's been a
disturbing spike in harassment
intimidation threats of violence against
school administrators board members
teachers and staff who participate in
the vital work of running our nation's
public schools the vital work that we
shut down for a year over a cough while
spirited cough that didn't propose any
particular threat to children while
spirited debate about policy matters is
protected under our constitution that
protection does not extend to threats of
violence or efforts to intimidate
individuals based on their views
threats against public servants are not
only illegal they run counter to our
nation's core values
yeah so now it's all about these three
it's really it's called is the matt
walsh memo
right this is don't show up to the
school districts and tell them what you
want this is a threat and it's domestic
terror and we got to stop it
something tells me
merrick garland would not have sent out
such a memo
over the blm riots
blm which was actually not just
threatening people but actually killing
people and stealing their property and
burning down their homes and businesses
and attacking federal courthouses you
probably wouldn't but but you
suburban mom who doesn't want your kid
being fed this racial and sexual poison
in the schools
that all white people are evil and
that america's an evil place and that
boys can be girls and that boys should
mutilate themselves if they feel like
girls so when they're four years old or
something if you oppose that you're
you're the terrorist you're the threat
it's such a sh it's such a charade it's
such a farce have you ever received a
call text or email from someone posing
as an irs agent a police officer or the
power company demanding payment by a
gift card i've had these sorts of things
happen to my relatives if you have
you're probably being targeted for a
gift card scam these fraudsters trick
victims into sending online gift cards
or reading the numbers from a gift card
over the phone good thing there's
lifelock lifelock helps detect a wide
range of identity threats like your
social security number for sale on the
dark web if they detect that your
information has potentially been
compromised they will send you an alert
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep what's yours
with lifelock by norton join now and
save up to 25 off your first year at
lifelock.com
knowlescanwles
that is lifelock.com slash knowles for
25 off protect yourself protect your
identity protect your data today
lifelock.com
knowles kwles for 25 off i'm i'm just
shocked that the department of justice
had time to craft this memo
when uh when they're usually just so
busy trying to entrap radical right
wingers at
at honeypot picnics do you remember that
you remember the justice for january 6th
rally and who showed up to the justice
for january 6th it was the press
and it was more press and it was
undercover fbi agents
who who were sticking out they were
glowing in the dark as could be it was
like a sore thumb
that's what it is
we talked about this yesterday because
there was a ku klux klan hoax it turned
out to be a 30 year old black woman
woman was pretending to be a klansman
and
threatening her neighbors
and and i pointed out to you that the
membership of the ku klux klan in the
united states is about 50 hoax artists
like the 30 year old black woman and 50
federal law enforcement officials
and like one guy and jimbo in the
mountains somewhere there's all he
didn't get the memo that the ku klux
klan hasn't been a thing for decades but
that's it it's all just a farce it's not
real the the show that you're seeing
before you
playing out at the level of the federal
government is not particularly
real
all right what what you're really seeing
here is the weaponization of the arms of
the government
and also of a fictional narrative to
stomp out any kind of dissent
if you oppose
flooding the country with illegal aliens
who harass senators in bathrooms if you
oppose
i don't know shipping manufacturing jobs
overseas if you oppose getting rid of
election integrity measures if you
oppose the separation of powers if you
oppose the slaughter of a million babies
a year why you're a domestic terrorist
and you need to be stomped at and if you
oppose critical race theory and radical
gender theory and teaching your little
boy that he should should mutilate his
genitalia to become a little girl
because that's totally possible
then you're a domestic terrorist
and you do not have the right to dissent
we support vigorous debate unless you
disagree with us then
then they try to stomp you out i'm so
glad you liked that clip if you want the
whole episode you can subscribe here you
know ring the bell hit the smash do the
whatever i don't know on youtube you can
do that that's fine but if you want the
full show without any of the big tech
censorship i would go check it out at
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your podcasts you
can subscribe for free to the michael
knowles show we'll see you there
[Music]
[Music]